well where there's disaster you'll find
the red cross they jumped into action in
ida's hard-hit areas to help and they've
also been very busy in the wildfire
areas here in the west also with
evacuations from afghanistan here this
morning to talk more about their
disaster relief efforts is red cross
president and ceo gail j mcgovern good
morning
president mcgovern it's really nice to
talk with you this morning let's talk
about these natural disasters forcing
families from their homes how does the
red cross help what's the first thing
you do
well first of all i i do want to thank
you for having me on the show and i want
to say my heart just goes out to
the people that have been impacted by
these natural disasters is truly
heartbreaking and as you mentioned
people lost loved ones they've lost
their homes um their belongings and
you know it's uh it's really devastating
and in terms of what the first thing is
that we do is when we see a storm coming
we start pre-positioning supplies and
volunteers
and we will open up shelters which is
what we've done we're out in the
communities now with emergency response
vehicles providing hot meals and
we also are giving out cleanup kits
start mucking out of their homes
and we have health counselors and mental
health counselors
in the community as well because they're
going through a tremendous amount of
trauma as you can imagine
i can't it is hard to imagine we see the
pictures of the damage and the
devastation
ms mcgovern the need seems greater than
ever climate specialists blaming climate
change the president's talking about it
what is the red cross seeing when you're
out there are the disasters bigger are
they more frequent is are they more
damaging what are you finding
well the answer to those last three
things is yes yes and yes um
you know as you mentioned we're also
dealing with the wildfires out in the
west and some of our volunteers i mean
this is almost three months that we've
been dealing with these wildfires
so you know i've been with the red cross
for
13 years now and you know just a few
years ago we would expect maybe two or
three acute storms that we would respond
to or disasters that we would respond to
but now it seems to be chronic it seems
to be happening all the time and
you know the climate experts have said
that the reason that ida was picked up
so much speed and was so damaging was
because of uh the ocean temperatures
rising
and you know the drought in california
is certainly causing these wildfires
and experts also say that by the year
2030 organizations like the american red
cross
will be responding to disasters not
so we
i it's hard for me to think of another
organization that is impacted by climate
change any more than uh the american red
cross
and and it's not only just natural
disasters from mother nature but you're
also supporting refugees coming in from
afghanistan afghanistan talk about that
what are you doing to help there
so there are about a dozen intake
centers where the american red cross is
helping out and we've provided hundreds
of volunteers and we've helped over 10
000 people as they are
getting to the us and it's heartbreaking
i mean these folks are presenting with
nothing
uh missing shoes soiled clothing their
kids have nothing it's very very
traumatic and um it's a privilege for us
to
respond the department of defense asked
us to do this and we are helping you
know give the kids toy hygiene kids
uh it's really extraordinary the work
that that we're doing and
all of this is because of the
generosity of the american public and i
would just ask that your viewers get in
touch with our website it's redcross.org
or our 800 number which is 1 800 red
cross because we could always use more
volunteers financial donations
regardless of size deeply appreciated
and also donate blood
thank you gail mcgovern i can only
imagine uh what a mountain you have to
climb in helping these people get their
lives back together thank you so much
for your time we appreciate it and best
of luck to you
thank you